hello everybody and welcome to today's
webinar this is a 704 series of three
where we have been looking at different
aspects of cell death in this session I
will talk to you about the different
types of cell death that has been
described up to date and how we can
differentiate between them as I've
mentioned in this session we will look
at different type of caspase dependent
and independent cell death and what are
the key markers for each type so let's
have a recap about cell death and the
different types
what is cell death cell death is an
essential mechanism that takes place in
multicellular organisms and we know if
it's important because the regulation of
cell death is at the basis to multiple
disorders if cell death occurs when it's
not necessary it can lead to pathologies
such as type 1 diabetes likes acid death
or the pancreatic beta-cells or
autoimmune diseases like rheumatoid
arthritis on the other hand if cell
death is not is not active when it
should it can lead to hyper
proliferative conditions of which cancer
is the best known example and why is
important to understand cell death
mechanisms because as you probably know
there are multiple ways by which a cell
can die from experimental mechanistic
opponent view we want to know how cell
death events are happening but for
material beauty point of view this
information can help us to find an
appropriate treatment for the disorder
so for example tumor cells are generally
resistant to chemotherapy link agents
that induce apoptosis so perhaps in
these cells we can use agents that
induce cell that by necrosis to kind of
get rid of them and so before we study
how cells are doing we have to ensure
the cell is dead and just once more let
me remind you how to clarify it when a
cell is s so according to the NCC D the
nomenclature committee on cell death
researchers should define a cell
death when the following features are
observed the cell has lost the plasma
membrane integrity the cell has
undergone completely disintegration and
whatever is left of the cell has been
forgotten by the neighboring cells in
vivo we already look briefly at the
different types of cell death in our
previous webinar but let's have a quick
refresh this is a classical view of the
different types of cell death but most
of us are familiar with we talked of up
herb Joseph's as a specific type of
programmed cell death whereas necrosis
is considered non programmed cell death
well as we mentioned previously this
view is no longer that simple the
nomenclature committee of cell death
suggests that cell death types can feed
into two mutually exclusive subtypes
accidental cell death
that's know involve molecular machinery
and cannot be modulated this type is
unlikely to happen in vivo and reflects
more the conditions than in vitro cells
can be exposed to like being frozen
improperly the type of cell death we all
have in mind falls within the regulated
cell death which involves a molecular
machinery and therefore can be modulated
and within regulated cell deaths we find
programmed cell death which happens as
part of the development program or to
preserve tissue homeostasis so here you
can see an overview of all the different
types of regulated cell death that have
been described so far according to the
NC CD so you can see that we don't talk
nowadays of just up closest and the
crosses but that we differentiate
between non program and program cell
death and that we seen program cell
death there is a broad range of cell
death types so let's look at program
versus known program and which is
mentioned necrosis is a regulated but
not programmed cell death mechanisms
necrosis is generally defined by a lack
of
program cell death features this means
that if dying cells do not show
apoptotic or any of the other type of
cell death features then they are
considered necrotic but necrotic cells
do have some defining morphological and
biochemical features and some of them
are for instance no ATP is required to
trigger necrosis in in vivo conditions
the release of the cellular content can
close in cause inflammation of the
surrounding tissues and necrotic cells
shows swelling following by Carol Isis
which is the dissolution of the
chromatin on the nucleus there are no
assays to really look at necrosis per se
but they are few markers that can be
used to define cell death and necrotic
however they have to be used in the
right context for instance release of
LDH lactate dehydrogenase can be
considered as a necrotic marker the
lysis of the cells will lead to the
release of the cytoplasmic content into
the culture medium so as you can see on
the image on the left well we have
measure release of LD h into the medium
and then broken-down cells will give a
higher signal that helps yourself as we
discuss in our apoptosis webinar
analysis of phosphatidylserine exposure
which is considered apoptotic marker in
conjunction with viability noise can be
used to discriminate between the
critique and apoptotic cells so as you
can see on the image on the right we can
see how jagged cells treated with estar
whispering can die by apoptosis shown in
green or necrosis shown in red remember
however that timing is very important
when we look at with fatigue is having
exposure as the later stages of cell
death even necrotic cells will show PS
exposure so let's look now at customs
dependent program cell death
apoptosis is the most well known caspin
caspase dependent cell type
but caspases can also be involved in
other lesser-known types such as annoy
keys or pyroptosis so let's look at them
in a bit more detail see what are they
do you need defining features and how we
can differentiate between them and
although we devoted our previous webinar
to apoptosis let's just have a quick
look at it again the extrinsic apoptotic
pathway is in use by the extracellular
signals that are sent and propagated by
specific transmembrane receptors such as
fast cdc 95 trail or TNF alpha
activation of these receptors leads to
activation of caspase 8 which in turn
leads to activation of the effect of
downstream caspases kospi 3 and 7 to
activate proteins that will lead to cell
fragmentation the intrinsic apoptotic
pathway on the other hand can be
triggered by intracellular stress
conditions such as DNA damage or
oxidative stress all controls to the
mitochondria activation of the proper
protocol of the bcl-2 family lead to
premiere realization of the
mitochondrial membrane releasing a +1 in
other proteins in order to form the
apoptosis which includes active
caspase-9 active caspase-9
will in turn activate the affected on
shrinker spaces especially in Kosrae 7
to activate proteins that will lead to
said fragmentation so what defines
apoptosis
historically apoptosis has been defined
by two morphological features which
include running up of the cell's nuclear
fragmentation or plasma membrane
blebbing
however as morphological features can be
shared by various different types of
cell death as we will see in later
slides here apoptosis is better defined
by biochemical features such as
activation of proper protocol
family members caspase activation and
all aglow nucleosomal DNA fragmentation
we discuss in detail all these features
and methods to detect them in our
previous webinar about apoptosis markers
so I would recommend you to look at it
if you want to know more about those
details about apoptosis the apoptosis
markers webinar is available to watch on
demand from our webinar library right so
we review apoptosis let's now look at
other caspase dependent cell death types
let's first look at annoyed case annoy
kiss is related to apoptosis and it
shares many of apoptotic features such
as caspase activation and activation of
parappa protic bcl-2 family members beam
and beads in particular in normal
conditions when adherent cells are
attached to the extracellular matrix
integrins present present in the
membrane are responsible for inducing /
survival signals when the interaction
with the stress cellular matrix is lost
this pro survival signal is inhibited
and the intrinsic apoptotic pathway is
activated probably through be member
active accumulation but this process is
not yet clearly understood I know it is
it's important because it prevents the
rehydration of cell into new matrices
when a notice is not functional an
adherent cell is able to survive in
suspension or is able to grow and
proliferate in a different location and
this is generally what happens in
metastatic conditions one is a way to
assess where the cells are dying by
notice is by assessing the cell
viability using an encourage resistant
plate here you can see how BJT third
cells are able to grow on a normal plate
that's on the top section of the image
you can see on the top left side the
live cells are stained with calcium
which is alive
when the cells are grown on a plate that
doesn't allow the adhesion I can
encourage your system plate the cells
start to die so you can see there is a
lack of calcium signal on the bottom
left image the appearance of nuclear
condensation visible by using a specific
membrane impermeable dye called
aetherium homodimer confirms that we are
looking at annoyed keys
so let's look now at pyroptosis
pyroptosis is an inflammatory Custis
typical space dependent form of cell
death that happens after microbial
infection morphologically periodic cells
look like necrotic cells but the cell
death is driven by inflammatory cases
caspase-1 mainly and cafes for invoice
or caspase 11 in mice acid depends on
caspase activation pyroptosis shares
some apoptotic features such as DNA
fragmentation or nuclear condensation
pyroptosis he is initiated by the
activation of canonical or non canonical
inflammasome the canonical inflammasome
is activated when the node like
receptors detect pathogens unrecruited
the ASC adapter protein which leads to
the Murrays ation and activation of
caspase 1 the non-canonical pathway is
activated by Libba polysaccharide
directly binding and activating caspase
11 in mice or caspase 4 and 5 in humans
in summer some activation will then lead
to gas Thurmond II cleavage which will
drive the onset of pyroptosis so who are
the key players to study when trying to
look at pyroptosis
caspase-1 which is involved in canonical
inflammation formation and responsible
for clearing Gutterman d caspase 4 & 5
in human or castes 11 in noise we
chime balls in the non-canonical
inflammasome information and responsible
for clearing gaza mindy and gas them
indeed which you start to be the
executioner of pyroptosis probably
through this equation of lb beta
annihilating although it is not clear
yet how this works so here some tools
you can use to study pyroptosis custom
in d the executioner of pyroptosis is a
53 kilodalton protein that is clip in a
forty three and a thirty kilo dalton
band when active we have well recently
launched a rabbit monoclonal against
castor Mindy and we have confirmed this
specificity of the antibody using a
knockout cell line that does not express
Goodell Mindi as you can see here on the
right
another key protein involving Parab
doses is caspase-1 caspase one can
easily be detected as a forty five kilo
Dalton run in Western blot upon
activation mature caspase-1 can then be
detected as a forty kilo Dalton band
however as we discuss in our previous
webinar to ensure that Cliff caspase-1
is active you should perform an activity
as a and here as you can see on the
image on the right so if both
opportunities and pyroptosis archive
space dependents elder types how can we
differentiate it well they're quite they
have quite different morphological and
biochemical features which have been
highlighted in green here in this table
I would say that the main distinctive
features are that pyroptosis displays
elliptic and inflammatory morphology in
vivo that the effector caspases
caspase-3 seven and six are not involved
in Perak ptosis and the probe cleavage
is not really observed in pair of ptosis
so and as we have discussed previously
to be able to define the type of cell
death we need to analyze
multiple markets because as we've seen
some of them can be shared between
different types so let's now look at
caspase independent cell death types so
neck rope disease and syrup ptosis are
the most well known mechanisms of
caspase independent cell death but they
are other minor pathways such as entosis
ona ptosis which has been described
recently so let's go through some of
these in more detail so let's talk about
necroptosis first
necroptosis is a caspase independent
form of program necrosis morphologically
necrotic cells look like necrotic cells
the most defining feature of necroptosis
is the activation of the rib kinases
specifically raped a nursery and the
pseudo kinase ml KL necroptosis it's
inhibited by caspase-8 so in the
majority of your scenarios cells will
choose to die through apoptosis through
caspase-8 activation
however some pathogens are able to
innovate caspase-8 activation and in
these cases necroptosis is an important
backup system to destroy these cells the
best receptors are involved in
activation of the extrinsic pathway are
responsible for necroptosis activation
as well so normal conditions the deaths
remain of the receptors recruits the per
survival complex one which involves a
poly poly ubiquitinated web kinase 1
when RHIB kinase 1 is d ubiquitinated
and caspase-8 is active a complex called
complex 2a is formed leading to
activation of apoptosis
if however
caspase-8 has been inhibited another
complex called complex to be is formed
complex to be recruits and activates rib
kinase 3 which in turn phosphorylates ml
KL in order to trigger the necrotic
pathway in some specific circumstances
activation of necroptosis can occur
independently of death receptors be a
toll like receptors TLR or viral
infections activation of toll like
receptor 3 or 4 recruits the adapter
protein trees which forms a complex with
red coin a3 and then activates a Mel
Cal's viral DNA can be recognized by the
AI a which stands for DNA dependent
activation of interferon regulatory
factors di I can recruit directly Ripken
III in order to activate ml KL so who
are the key players to analyze to
investigate whether necrosis is involved
in our type of cell death the reply
native web kinase one and specifically
web kinase 3 which are involved in their
custom recruitment phosphorylated ml k
which is the mediator of the cell death
and caspase-8 because inhibits
necroptosis although minor players are
the the ubiquity noise see while LD and
you'll be getting like ISO C IP 1 and C
IP 2 so here are some tools you can use
to study necroptosis mikl activation can
be studied using an antibody against
phosphorylated serine 3 5 8 which is a
residue phosphorylated by Ripken a3 and
is necessary for MLK el tema resection
and activation so here we treated HT 29
cells which is a human colorectal
adenocarcinoma cell line with TNF alpha
SMAC mimetic molecule and C fat as this
treatment this treatment has been shown
to induce ml KL activation on the bottom
section you can see another for specific
antibody which is detecting in this case
phosphorylated serine 2 to 7 or web
karna 3
we have also induced web kinase
reactivation
tnf-alpha smack mimetic molecule and see
file and also I wanted to show you this
load in particular to demonstrate that
we also get dirty blood and some
antibodies give extra bands no matter
how beautiful they are so now that we
have learned about a cup necroptosis the
main khud space independence of this
pathway let's briefly describe some
other minor pathways the Farah proces is
a normal form of cell death which is
independent on class basis the
morphology of our up-top syrup taught
excels is actually quite different from
both apoptotic uh necrotic cells the
main defining morphologic feature seems
to be that mitochondria are smaller with
increased membrane density also in
therapeutics cells there is a lack of
plasma membrane rupture of leveling and
there is no nuclear condensation
parabiosis is characterized by the
accumulation of lipid peroxidation
products and reactive oxygen species
derived from IO metabolism for up ptosis
can be triggered by inhibiting the
system xe- responsible for maintaining
the video from a stasis by importing
cysteine cysteine which is reduced to
sustain and use the synthesized
glutathione the major antitoxin molecule
in cytosol depletion of glutathione
peroxidase 4 has also been shown to
induce or up ptosis as the lipid
peroxide cannot be reduced so the main
mark is to look an induction of
apoptosis our losses iron the main
antioxidant molecule in the cell and
with the thorium peroxidase full
inhibition of any of them can induce
Phillip ptosis I will briefly talk about
Auto Fuji or auto fat chicks elders
autophagy is characterized by the
sequestration of cytoplasmic material
vesicles called autofocus ohms where
they will be decorated by lysosomal
enzymes initially al-tofah Jie was
described as cell death pathway type to
an incident in a specific cases Auto V G
can be involved in cell death but it is
so nowadays that in the majority of a
scenarios out of G seems to promote cell
survival and not cell death and because
of this and because it's a whole topic
in itself out of a G won't be discussed
further in this webinar but if you would
like to know more about APPA G please
have a look at our Auto veggie guide
available for download at outcomes
dot-com slash out of GE book and then
they are other lesser-known
or well study pathways such as the ones
you can say in the list pass on others
is a regulated necrosis characterized by
over activation of club and ATP ATP
depletion neurosis is a pathogen induce
cell death specifically in natural field
characterized by the release of a
chromatin structures cornet and ptosis
happens when a cell invades another one
and this has been called cell
cannibalism it is characterized by
activation of the Rho G TPAs
and it downstreams effector rock so now
that we have review an extensive list of
multiple types of cell death we want to
know of course how do we know which one
is happening in our system so there are
few key questions and issues to consider
before you start thinking about starting
lots and lots of markers so for instance
what exactly is triggering cell death in
our model a macabre logical pathogen is
more likely to activate self-destructive
cell death by a death receptors than by
directing
directly limiting molecules which is an
a mechanism of action that we'll
probably see in cells treated with
biochemical
compound so this can help us to already
have an idea of which type of cell is
more likely to be triggered another key
issue to look at are the morphological
features display by the cells in vitro
and in vivo many of the features
described here like inflammation won't
be seen and in vitro cultures there are
other features like obvious chromatin
condensation then can help us to discard
which that type is not happening one of
the most useful questions to investigate
is whether the death is affected by
certain conpine we look at this in the
next slide by chemical inhibition or
genetic inhibition if available
can help us to investigate which
molecules and proteins are involved in
the cell death and then we can be able
to specify the type of cell death that
we're looking at so following this type
of key questions let's see how we can
try to pinpoint which type of cell death
is happening in our system so if for
instance we look at ourselves in the
microscope and we see that they are
shrinking and not exploding we're
probably looking at about ptosis so in
this case we should look at a range of
apoptosis markers for confirmation just
as we discussed in this previous webinar
if we think that we are looking at our
notice perhaps because there is theme
over expression or the cell line we are
using is known to metastasize we my 1
then to test if the cells can survive in
an encourage resistant plate if we look
at ourselves and then there's some
swelling and noises then we're probably
looking at some other type of regulated
necrosis if our cell type that we are
using is a neutrophil we could be
looking under ptosis if the cell death
is prevented by C Y D ID and some K
which is a caspase-1 inhibitor then we
are likely to be looking at pyroptosis
Abe the cell death is prevented by
Nicolas Cage
theme which is a rib kinase 1 inhibitor
then it's likely to be necroptosis the
cell that is probating by favored
starting which is a liquid a lipid rasa
scavenger then is likely to be for up
ptosis and so on and so on and if cell
death can be prevented by any compound
we test then we might actually be
looking at necrosis so please keep in
mind that this is just one example of
the multiple ways you could use to
analyze what type of cell death you're
looking at because in most experimental
cases you are likely to already have an
idea of what is happening in your model
so you're more likely to want to
differentiate between just two
potentials cell death pathways and not 5
or 6 like we show in here because
remember just because all these pathways
have been described it doesn't mean that
they all can be triggered in all same
models and of course in each case once
we think we're looking at a cell type we
still have to look at the key markers
for each of them so in this table we
have tried to summarize the defining
characteristics of each of the main cell
death pathways that have been described
up-to-date apoptosis can be triggered by
death receptor activation or
intracellular signals whereas pyroptosis
it triggered by pathogens activated
inflammations similar to the extrinsic
apoptotic pathway necroptosis can be
triggered by also by dead receptor
activation but only when caspase-8 is
inhibited parabiosis is triggered by ion
dependent lipid peroxides
necrosis is a toxicity induced cell
death and does not require any specific
triggering stimuli all these type of
cell death except apoptosis
can generate an inflammatory response in
vivo initiator caspases and bcl-2 family
proteins are the key defining proteins
involved in triggering apoptosis oh
makerspaces in this case inflammatory
cases together with dusty Mindy are
involved in pyroptosis the rib kinase is
1 and 3 and the pseudo kinase ml KL are
responsible for the onset of necroptosis
inhibition of glutathione peroxidase 4n
glutathione leads to activation of
parabiosis the executioner caspases
Casspi 3 & 7 mainly are responsible for
executing apoptosis
whereas intellect in one Vita and
Interlaken 18 also to execute our
obsessives although as we mentioned this
pathway still not very well defined how
necroptosis is executed is still unclear
and an increase in cellular reactive
oxygen species and decreasing
glutathione pool seems to be involved in
the later stages of parabiosis knowing
which compounds innovate h mechanisms of
cell death is a very useful tool as we
have seen in the previous slide since we
can use it to analyze which type of cell
death we're looking at apoptosis can be
inhibited by see fat m'kay or qvd both
well known broadcast ACE inhibitors
caspase-1 inhibitor SI y SI y VA d FM k
is commonly used to inhibit pyroptosis
necroptosis can be inhibited by addition
of necklace 18 1g Sarab kinase one
individual only Castleford sulfonamide
IM l KL inhibitor and ferb doses can be
inhibited by favor starting one or
liberal starting one and although
morphology
cannot should not be used to
differentiate between the different
types of cell death it still gives a
value of information for us
when using context apoptotic cells show
a quite different morphology from the
other cell types such as surrounding
plasma blabbing and formation of
apoptotic bodies
parabiosis and necroptosis
shares a morphological
choose such as the rupture of the plasma
membrane and release of cell content the
rep topic cells have a very distinct for
morphology such as mola mitochondria
which is a feature that is not seen in
any other cell type
so as we have seen cell death is a
complex business and because what often
happens in life what often happens is
life systems is that cells that are in
the same tissue or culture conditions
and even if they are treated the same
way they can die by different mechanisms
and this is because cell death can be
influenced by several things the type of
is stimulus for instance different type
of stimuli are more likely to activate
some types of cell death than others the
cell type some cell types are more
likely to activate some Delfy some Delta
cell death pathways like for instance
NATO sees is only seen in neutrophils
the cell environment in an in vivo
environment for example cells closer to
a blood vessel will hit a higher
concentration of a mycological compound
than they wants farther away and this
could lead to activation of different
cell death pathways and the cell
physiological state a cell there is
entering mitosis will probably respond
differently than one that touches finish
mitosis and the cell that has a mutation
has mutations might activate different
pathways as well so this brings us to
the end of the webinar with few
take-home messages remember that cells
can die by a spectrum of cell death
types even under the same stimulus on
the same tissue or cell culture each
cell type can be defined by particular
morphological and biochemical features
and although those morphological
features can help to suggest white type
of cell death is happening
the underlying biochemical mechanisms
need to be studied and confirmed make
sure that you use activators and
especially inhibitors of the different
pathways in order to confirm or discard
what type of cell death you are studying
apoptosis is the most studied form of
programmed cell death for a reason so if
in doubt I would suggest to first
confirm all this card apoptosis in your
model before you start looking into
other types of cell death and as we have
repeated through this series of this
webinar always take your experimental
model and settings in consideration
before you draw any conclusions so thank
you very much for your attention I am
ready now to answer any questions yes
so one first question is what is the
best way to detect pyroptosis and
necroptosis in situ there are as you
might see - you mean directly in a
tissue so that's actually the best way
because you can see how is happening in
an in vivo model so obviously you might
have some ideas looking in situ might
give you some information about whether
there's inflammation happening another
way it could be using antibodies against
the active proteins so for instance for
necroptosis you could use the force for
specific chemical antibody and so yet I
would say probably morphology in
combination with some immunity or
chemistry staining that would be one of
the best ways another question is can an
apoptosis cells express bcl-2 on
administer chemistry for example a tumor
cell yes I mean bcl-2
any of the pco2 family members is
probably expressed in one level or
another what is going to happen in an
aprotic cells is that the balance
between the
bcl-2 molecules and the level of proper
toting members such as back spot is on
the favor of the proper protocol so you
could detect some bcl-2 expression you
might want to compare it maybe with
treated control and see what's the level
and an untreated control Sudama gives
you an idea whether this training is
just a basal level or actually there's
something happening in your model and
another question is I know a kid can
also be called apoptosis for example
what if annoyed is is also positive for
tunnel and as we mentioned and I know
this is a specific type sort of
apoptosis and so what is likely to
happen that a lot of the markets that
you see for our purposes pretty much all
of them I would say appear in annoy keys
but when I notice is different is
because it has to do with the cell
environment so what is going to happen
is that because your cell your cell is
able to survive in suspension with a
normal cell will just die and that's the
way you can detect it it's also tricky
when we look at our cells in culture
because most of the cells that we all
have in culture are some sort of tumor
cell in a sword so they are likely that
they could survive in they could have
their annoy keys pathway inhibited so
you could see that probably the best way
to see is in your cell model annoy
kisses individual is by using the
encourage plate because I will tell you
that actually that cell type is able to
grow even when encouraged is not needed
so that could give you that sort of
information but it's very likely that
you're going to see very very similar
markets as apoptosis because at the end
of the day I practice and I know it is a
sort of a subset of apoptosis it's just
apoptosis happening in a very specific
model and another question is are these
cell death mechanisms mortally exclusive
or can they coexist
it depends with you
what do you mean by Motel exclusive what
happens I think in one particular cell
probably only one of them is happening
but of course you're not looking at one
individual cell at a time usually when
we do the experiments we look in a cell
culture in a tissue context and then
what happens is that you might see
different types of cell death happening
in the same culture as we said and also
if you remember when we were talking
about necrosis and I showed the
apoptosis and necrosis kit on the same
cell culture we were seeing apoptosis
and necrosis so yes they can happen some
of them can happen in the same culture
but not on the same cell and that's
going to depend again on the type of
yourself on the stimuli and so you have
to take that into context
for instance some cells they will behave
differently when they're exposed to low
concentrations of a drug and they will
have a they will trigger different type
of cell death when they exposed to high
concentrations so that's something you
have to keep in mind I guess a society
is the best way we can say is well in
the majority of my cell model this is
the type death that is happening and
therefore you could be quite confident
that that's the cell type you're looking
at the question is regulated in a sense
comes under program don't you think well
yes it is and the difference I think
when when we talk about program what
we're saying is that there is some
specific there's a trigger that will
make that cell death pathway happening
and I think when people try and between
program and non program is that of
course necrosis is regulated when the
tissue the body makes them cells and
tissue going to necrosis is because
something has been it's happening is
necessary for that tissue to go into
necrosis the main difference between the
program is that the program
tends to really refer to very specific
cell types and there's some stimuli
required but I agree with you maybe
something that is more semantic
difference and actually the difference
in function and that's so there's very
types depend on the cell cycle phase on
the cell and it might do again as I said
a cell that is entering in in mitosis
will have different proteins activated
than a one that has just gone through so
there will be different checkpoints and
in action p53 might be involved in p53
we know sometimes might be involved in
blocking up of ptosis so it might depend
again in in vivo and in ourselves it's
all a living system so you have to look
into the context of where the majority
of the cells are happening in what's
going on over a period of time and
another question is how to differentiate
between a notice and apoptosis by a st.
Marcus I believe I have answered those
questions before as I said apoptosis and
annoy keys are kind of the same the main
differences and Noah keeps happens when
a cell is not able to survive on
suspension but if you believe I haven't
answered that question please let me
know and I'll try to get through that
again do you recommend a particular
agent inducing for annuities because I
say annoy kids in a way superb Tosi's I
presume it will depend under your type
of cell and I notice in will be induced
when a cell that should be attached is
not attached so probably using the unco
and encourage resistant light would be a
good way to induce annoy keys does the
collagen degrade in the fibrotic tissue
belong to cell death and what kind of
cell does ooh those are really good
tricky question at the same time I
really don't know I would have to do a
bit more digging I would say that the
degradation of the collagen is a
collateral action of the type of cell
death because I guess what you want to
see is that the cells within the
collagen matrix what's happening with
them so you might want to look into two
different ways you might want to look
just are your cells outside of that
collagen matrix first and see what's
happening and then what's happening in a
run when they still cells are with the
collagen and might be triggered
different senses I like to think that
it's probably some sort of of lytic cell
death so it's going to be probably a
kind of caspase independent just because
caspase independent cell death tend to
release sort of the cell contents and
that tends to create an sort of lytic
mode around the tissue so another
question says if I'm not grown it has
been reported necroptosis necrosis like
morphology of cell death with caspase-8
and caspase-3 involved what would that
be then I think dies more likely to be
necroptosis because they the downstream
pathway of necroptosis are still not
clear so I would not discard the fact
that maybe there's some Class B 3 and
again it comes back to what I was saying
that it depends if you mean there's
caspase-3 in the culture of this Gatsby
3 in the cell so it could be then is
very likely that on the same cell
culture using different types of cell
death and another question is can we use
ATP levels and LDH release to
differentiate between apoptosis and
necrosis you could look at that
initially just to give maybe a quick
idea am i looking at this am i looking
at that
but if if you wanted to make sure that
you're looking at apoptosis then you
have to look at some other apoptotic
markers but definitely if what you're
seeing is maybe no changes on the ATP
levels and LVH release at early stages
because obviously at some point later on
all the cells are going to die and the
whole culture is going to go Hollywood
long so you're likely to have a lot of
LDH in the culture regardless then that
could get one idea and another question
is how can I prove caspase independent
cell death well you can use the caspase
inhibitors like we say see fat and their
qvd and if then you don't see any effect
then it's quite likely that you're not
going to see the cell death are you
looking at is caspase independent
another question is when I analyze
tissue prepare from diseased animal
models are so many pi not excels but
many of them are negative for channel
and click especially by IHC what is your
recommendation Oh a good question and
for that one if it's okay with you I
will follow up with you offline because
then I have time to look through my
notes and look in more detail what type
you're looking at so if that's okay I'll
follow that question offline and the
still dares mechanism change from one to
another for example cells die brain
necroptosis which express their cells to
neighboring cells by parabiosis if you
to dump from necrotic cells that can
trigger the inflammasome that is quite a
model indeed and to be honest the
question is I don't know I think it
could change slightly and I don't think
it's likely that you're going to see a
huge change from a necroptosis so from
my caspase independent to then i
caspere's dependent to them to a
necrotic what i slightly what i think it
would happen is that the surrounding
cells are out that initial cell are
going to have very similar type of cell
death and then if they stimuli that it's
provoking that cell that it's not passed
to the other cells some of them might be
affected by some of the dams some of
them might not so and actually that
follows can go to the next question
someone saying I have heard of dams
could you tell me what they are
so Dam stands for damage associated
molecular patterns so these are
molecules that can be into for instance
an inflammatory response if there's no
infection so it's what kind of what we
see in necrosis and necroptosis so
that's kind of what it is um